let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
friday
the 13th
and poor little elon musk
still doesn't own twitter
silence
from the elon stands this morning
as elon announces uh
the twitter deal is on hold
uh someone said that i was uh i was a
prophet this morning
i'm not a prophet
it's really simple to see some of these
things it really is simple to see that
elon musk is a [ __ ] flake he's always
been a [ __ ] flake he will always be a
[ __ ] flake
and there might be alternative or
alternative motives to his [ __ ] that
he's doing or rather he's trying to make
more money or not he's losing a [ __ ] ton
of money
is the fact of the matter and i bet i
bet today i bet today me and gabe
sanchez my co-host and executive
producer i bet we chat
for a few minutes about uh elon's
problems
that's what's trending on twitter's
hashtag elon's problems
also we have
all the pro starvers out there they're
not pro lifers anymore they're pro
starvers
that's right we have to get this um we
have to get this language right
they're pro starvers you know
save the save the clump of cells starve
the children
that's their motto that's the republican
party's motto and this isn't new
it is not republicans wanting to starve
children is not a new concept this is
not a new thing
they've always been against wic a bank
against snap against the food stamps
part of the farm bill they've always
always been against children
getting food in this country especially
food
that could give them nutrition and save
their lives
i mean as george carlin said it best
if you're pre-born you're fine if you're
pre-school you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] that's george garland's
quote all the way back in the 19 mid
1990s
this is not a new concept that the
republicans want to starve children
especially
especially
brown children oh boy they really they
really are for that because you know it
says in the bible
starve the brown children
because
baby formula biden's fault
let's go brandon nazis
hell
[Music]
this is what we have to deal with today
i don't know what to tell you i i don't
i don't decide these things
this is just what happens in the news
this is just what happens
we have um some other news uh rand paul
loves putin
is this is this even a surprise either
that rand paul
this is not a new concept either i'm
gonna play you a [ __ ] video i know
it's out there somewhere when you go to
the rand paul feed
of john mccain
dunking on this [ __ ]
from years ago and this morning john
mccain is dunking on him from the grave
that he's putin's puppet
this is not new of course of course rand
paul would make sure that innocent women
and children in the ukraine
are not protected by money that the
united states has and could give to aid
those
in need of defense from a murderous
dictator like vladimir putin
but rand paul says nope
nope
save
the clump of cells but starve the
children and bomb the ukrainians baby
boom shakalaka pro-life
there you go there's you some pro-life
[ __ ] this morning again we have to
rebrand these [ __ ] as pro
starvers that's what they are pro
starvers and pro putin
pro putin starvers
they love it they love it they love the
[ __ ] about baby formula
not being on shelves you know then
forget the [ __ ] facts forget why
why we don't have baby formula on the
shelves
they don't want to talk about how maybe
we should socialize
maybe we should socialize
the delivery and the distribution of
baby formula they definitely don't want
to [ __ ] say anything about that holy
[ __ ] they do not want to get into the
conversation about the federal
government socializing
and taking away from private companies
the ability and the regulation
of producing baby formula so babies get
baby born they do not
you definitely do not want to go in
these threads
and say that to these [ __ ]
because that's what they're saying
they're saying oh it's biden's fault the
government needs to do something
you mean socialism you dumb
[ __ ]
we rely on private industry in this
country to deliver
millions and millions of families their
baby formula
we have incident
where there's a bacteria in a plant that
is killing children killing children you
pro starver [ __ ]
that breaks the supply chain in a region
of the country now if you know anything
about distribution and trucking and
shipping and supply chains you dumb
[ __ ] if you pluck your head out
of your ass for two seconds and realize
when a certain region of the country
all of a sudden has their only factory
that produces baby formula to distribute
that said formula to the families in
that part of the country
then what you have to do is fill the gap
you have to ship that baby formula from
other parts of the country to that
region you dumb [ __ ]
and what it does is it creates supply
chain issues
not just in that region but other
regions this isn't [ __ ] rocket
science this isn't hard to understand
we went through this dip this [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] when the when the pipeline
down in georgia got shut down and they
were pumping gasoline into [ __ ]
grocery sacks
they just are not going to get it folks
they're not they're not going to
understand these issues
america
in a certain percentage
and most of them are cuban honors
trump-humping
[ __ ] maga morons that think donald
trump is their manga king
are [ __ ] dumb
they're [ __ ]
dumb
and they don't care what the facts are
they don't give a [ __ ]
as long as the almighty
republican jesus
the orange mussolini
as he were
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy
pants tells them that's the facts
by god that's the stupid [ __ ] facts
it says on facebook that trump said blah
blah blah blah blah so that's what i
believe
save the clump of cells starve the
children
that's what we do because there's there
are legals they're illegals
so that makes them non-human we
the bible says nothing nothing about
humanity
[ __ ] idiots
welcome friday to 13th and welcome to
all the listeners out there you guys
know we broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch just go to
youtube and search the tony michaels
podcast also we simulca cast
on midas touch facebook page if you're
over on the books of face welcome
welcome welcome
at the top of that post where our our
feed is there is a link to our youtube
channel you definitely want to go
subscribe there don't stop watching us
on facebook but go subscribe on youtube
because we have a lot of exclusive
videos that go over on youtube so you
definitely want to follow us there you
do not want to miss a
thing make sure to tune in every single
weekday monday through friday and today
is friday friday the 13th and you know
what friday means
friday means bonehead of the week
bonehead of the week where you vote for
bonehead of the week you decide and we
break down your vote
every single friday in the second hour
of the show that's right folks if you're
listening out there and you're a new
listener we do this show every single
weekday for two hours a day
every single weekday so don't forget to
tune in every single weekday also
if you don't tune in live don't worry
don't worry don't fuss
you can download the podcast on apple
spotify google
make sure to leave us a five star rating
over there the only rating
the only rating for this show that is
allowed over there understand i'm just
kidding you can leave any rating you
want
but help us out with the
with the ratings trolls they like to go
over there and leave bad ratings you
know that's how they like to do
so give us give us a boost over there
and again don't don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel
super super super important stuff folks
super important stuff you don't want to
miss a thing
all the clippy clips
when we go through the tweety tweets and
trendy trends if you if you guys are not
aware of your new listeners out there
we go through the tweety tweets and
trinity trends we call it the [ __ ] list
roundup so make sure to follow at tony
michael's pod follow me at the tony
michaels and follow the co-host at gabe
sanchez on twitter
and also at tony michael's pod is where
you can take the bonehead of the weak
pole
best part
best part is now we actually put the
pull on youtube that's right on the
tubes of you
the pole lives and breathes
so go over there and take the bonehead
of the week poll every single week
and join us in the super chat on youtube
every single friday during the bonehead
of the week breakdown
listen folks
we've got a lot of new listeners out
there let's look let's look and see who
we got this morning good morning
christina mind is robin kelly is here mj
good morning debbie from salt lake
forest is back again from facebook
we have skip here margie from facebook
is here nolan's here the 420 god is here
david is here janie's here
nancy's here lisa midas lisa's here
ray is here from facebook trina is here
from facebook holy moly we got so many
new listeners regina particia from
facebook uh uh david from facebook uh
holy moly yes dark pepsi's here uh
valerie is here amanda is here kaelin is
here uh lacey from facebook is here holy
moly look at all these listeners folks
look at all these listeners come join us
at the chat either on facebook or
youtube
get in on the super chat speaking of
super chat i think we got yes we do i i
want to show you something here we came
up with a good new uh we're
experimenting with animations you see
the animation here the dancing animation
thanks
thanks for the super chat thank you very
much minus lisa happy friday tony and
chat friends she says come join the
super chat
if you're over there on the books of
face if you're on twitter listening if
you're on twitch listening you may want
to join the youtube super chat and see
what that's about come find out
what the super chat's about thank you
very very much minus lisa we always
appreciate the support here
at the tony michaels podcast
now let's get into it let's not waste a
lot of time we got a lot of stuff to do
before we get to the bonehead of the
week because the bone ended
we got a lot of [ __ ] to get to there
so you know we like to round up the
tweety tweets in the trendy trends it's
friday the 13th let's round those
[ __ ] up
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show
this is the part of the tony michaels
podcast where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends someone in
the uh on on twitch says i couldn't find
bonehead of the uh poll
to vote yesterday we we got it out late
uh we'll have to give our executive
producer gabe sanchez some lashes
uh today when we get on bone of the week
listen just go follow at tony michael's
pod
every single friday morning we try to
keep it open you can now go to youtube
youtube has the poll not just twitter
so make sure you're subscribing to
youtube so you can vote for bonehead of
the week i think it was really close
this morning i'm not sure exactly what
the numbers look like on who won
bonehead of the week
today but uh we're gonna find out in the
breakdown so stay tuned for in the
entire show because in the second hour
we will go through the moon end of the
week and you will find out who the
winner is the other thing about the
bonehead of the week for the new
listeners is we also have a dishonorable
mention
and the alpha cuck so we'll have the
alpha cuck of the week and the
dishonorable mention of the week so stay
tuned
stay tuned to the second hour
oh boy there's a lot of stuff trending
this morning
um let's see let's let's just make this
a tad bit bigger so you folks out there
can see
and let's go through the tweety tweets
and trendy trends let's start on the
timeline you guys like this uh
here's the thumbnail for today
um i found
someone posted
this uh this picture of elon musk
um this is before his hair plugs i think
at least he committed to hair plugs you
know what i mean like he can't commit to
buying twitter but at least the guy
actually you know made the effort and
committed to the hair plugs
i don't know how many billions of
dollars he spent on those earplugs
hopefully
less than what he's gonna spend on
trying to get out of this deal to not
buy twitter
oh
that's right he's not gonna own twitter
won't own twitter never will own twitter
hasn't won't nope not gonna do it i've
been saying it from the very beginning
that this [ __ ] will never own
twitter
he's not why would he
why would he own twitter he's a [ __ ]
goof
he was trying to be a
a tough guy
and now he's not so [ __ ] tough i mean
jesus christ mj pointed out something
let me find it here mj or one of our
favorite here on the show let me let me
find uh
her tweet here here it is
uh no that's not that's a different one
i thought i retweeted it
oh boy
oh shuckums
um
it's here somewhere there it is
uh mj says i seem to recall saying the
same thing checks notes sorry haters it
was always a stock manipulation game for
musk
i'll bet he buys out the rest of his
fully vested tesla stock options really
soon [ __ ]
p.s
but but wasn't bot removal the plan she
points out a very good point she points
out a very good
uh
mj you're always on top of it
he was saying he was saying oh we're
gonna remove the bots we're not gonna
have bots on twitter anymore elon was
gonna
you know
exercise the bots from twitter i don't
know if he's gonna have like an exorcist
do it or i'm not sure what the hell the
point is but this morning the reason why
elon musk is putting the deal on hold
is because there's too many bots i guess
too many fake accounts
but wasn't that the [ __ ] point
i thought that was the point oh my god
i can't with these sons of [ __ ]
anymore
and i'm talking about the elon stands
i'd love elon musk elon musk provides us
plenty of content here on the tony
michael's podcast that bonehead can't
stop
cannot stop frankly here's his tweet
right here's elon musk's tweet from 17
hours ago even though i think it's less
div
i think a less divisive candidate would
be better in 2024 i still think trump
should be restored to twitter he's still
trying to get his stands to believe
that he's gonna [ __ ] bring back trump
on twitter
i said tots and payers
gotta own that [ __ ] first [ __ ]
you can't bring back trump if you don't
own it [ __ ]
what are you talking about
you're just you're just
[ __ ] giving meat to your stands so
they don't abandon you when you look
like a little [ __ ] because you tuck
tail and run on a deal
[ __ ] idiot
what a bonehead
we got a super chat here coming in
live super chat mj thank you very much
she says finally a good enough tweet oh
come on mj
come on
[Laughter]
mj we love you here
and uh i don't know if i guy is in the
uh chat here is eye guy with us today i
don't think he's been here since we
really um
we schooled him mj was in on school in
the eye guy mj knows her [ __ ] when it
comes to elon musk she's got him sniffed
out too
from the very beginning from the very
beginning someone uh
posted
i don't know it was like a
a a photoshop this morning um let me see
if i can find it here in the uh thread
[Music]
uh
where is it there's a picture
there it is
oh hang on i gotta take down the banner
you guys gotta see this
uh apparently i have a crystal ball here
then it kind of looked like maybe
i'm uh
i don't know
i don't know it looks like uh looks like
elon musk is really excited
they're in the crystal ball
i'm not sure exactly where they pulled
this picture of me from but it almost
looks like i'm either trying to fart or
i'm saying the word [ __ ] i can't tell i
can't tell exactly where they pulled
this video from of me this picture i'm
sure it's from a video that's a hell of
a face isn't it
oh thank you um [ __ ] trump
uh [ __ ] trumps
account uh posted it i think they i
think they made that graphic so everyone
spread
spread the tony
tony crystal ball uh tweet around
apparently they thought i
i um
i can see into the future and they also
said all's i have to all all i'll say is
at tony michaels at the tony michaels
was the first person to say that elon
musk wasn't buying twitter dude is a
prophet i don't know if i was the first
but
i definitely from the very beginning as
soon as the news broke i said this guy
is not going to own twitter no [ __ ]
way no [ __ ] how no you're not going
to own twitter he's not that's all
[ __ ]
not going to do it
you guys heard that the uh crypto is
crashing uh rachel bittikoffer has that
news here uh crypto bros finding out the
downsides of deregulation
rachel um poking fun at the elon stands
the crypto bros uh out there and thank
you rachel for the uh the dig
on them uh let's see here one we got
you got comments coming in like crazy
dude thanks you guys for being here
today and commenting back and forth
uh suzanne says i definitely called it i
try i try to call it here i and you guys
know
you guys know that
look
i say a lot just doubt me just doubt me
because it's easy to see what these
[ __ ] are gonna do it's not hard to know
who these [ __ ] people are they don't
hide it
they do not hide it from us it's right
out in the open
i mean jesus christ they're like ow
biden is making sure children don't eat
in this country
by
stopping baby formula from being made as
if joe biden stopped the factory from
making the [ __ ] baby formula that was
killing children
what are you talking about the regulator
stopped it because children died because
there was bacteria in the formula they
had to recall the [ __ ]
and then like the same breath oh them
brown kids down put them in cages and
let them starve [ __ ] them
that's the that's the that's the gqp
baby that's the republican party and
this isn't new this isn't new they've
always voted against wic they've which
if you guys don't know what wick is that
is the [ __ ] government program
that pays for formula for new babies new
infants
they [ __ ] hate wick [ __ ] wick that's
welfare we don't want to give you
broke-ass americans welfare
[ __ ] you pull yourself up by your
formula straps
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] they
always vote against snap any kind of
food assistance whatsoever even in the
farm bill they hate food stamps
in the farm bill so much so they
separated food stamps out of the farm
bill so they could vote for farmers to
get their their [ __ ] welfare but not
the [ __ ] children getting their
[ __ ] food this is the republican
party folks this isn't new concepts they
[ __ ] hate america they hate americans
they hate children the only thing they
love about children is when they can
[ __ ] marry them in in tennessee and
missouri and take their [ __ ] macbooks
away so they don't learn math they
definitely don't want these
[ __ ] to know math so they can
decipher how much formula they're
getting
and how much they're not getting
damn education damn children damn
america they [ __ ] hate america these
pro starvers speaking of a pro starver
here's what looks like to be a pro
starver right here look at this guy look
at this [ __ ] guy
what the [ __ ] is this gabe you gabe you
gotta you gotta get in here you see this
picture
this looks like uh some sort of
confederate uh
you know what this is this is like a diy
confederate superhero but like a super
loser you know
like this is the guy that's like hey
guys i'm going to comic con it's like
what's your costume i made it myself oh
really what is it i'm a confederate man
i'm a racist
like
like you would think you you would think
looking at this that this is like a
complete joke and it's like this
this cannot be this cannot be serious
and then you're like nope this guy
somehow found matching confederate pants
with the shirt and then not only that he
put in a goddamn two
two confederate flags as if there were
swords he was going to wield enough
goddamn gladiator games this is perfect
this is perfect this is the perfect
expression
of what the trump supporters want to be
will be and always are going to be
right here and i've i've i i've known
people like this frankly like in my life
i've i've seen these folks i've been
around these folks and i can't tell it's
hard to tell gabe is this his house or
is this like a thrift store this looks
like a thrift store and that he's so he
got himself
secondhand confederate
uh
here if you look here on the table here
there's some more what appears to be uh
bars and stars there as they call it and
so i don't know if like he came in to
get uh maybe a stars and bars cape from
federal thrift store i'm not really sure
i think the missing touch really is a
confederate flag that he draped as a
cake all right as a cape uh they might
they might eat confederate cakes i do i
i guarantee that if they were to if you
were to cut into a six layer cake
it would have red white blue white red
like it would and then stars and bars on
the end stars and bars dude that's what
it would be but the best thing is i
guarantee that all of this
all of these flags and hats and shirts
and pants and and whatever stuff is on
the table all made in china this guy's
proudly repping absolutely and he
probably he probably probably
continually says america first america
first with my chinese confederate pants
and my my chinese flags
what the hell what the hell is this uh i
don't even know liam nissan said he
posts this he says i voted i voted for i
think he's uh quoting this gentleman
here oh yeah probably
i voted for for jd mandel just like my
president trump told me
durrrr
i mean just like everything else i do
oh my god i i really appreciate this
picture being posted you know what you
know what i think i'd like to refer to
the confederate flag going forward
as the skidmark flag the skidmark the
skidmark flag skidmark
yeah you know i i think this is exactly
what a pro starver would look like gabe
oh
starver man yeah i mean we you know they
call themselves pro lifers but they're
pro starvers have you heard this have
you heard this this morning um there's a
bunch a bunch a bunch of bunch of
elected officials of course there are a
bunch of elect not just like
[ __ ] elon stands but there's a [ __ ]
ton
a [ __ ] ton of uh elected which by the
way i would
love to jump into so
uh there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
elon you mean yeah yeah yeah well let's
let's do the let's do the uh elise
um i believe i believe
i'm sorry can you sorry can you just
scroll up real quick i just want to see
that maggot king there we go that's that
thank you there you go you know you know
what paul should do paul should take the
picture that we just uh we just showed
um from liam nees i'm not trying to
create work for paul yeah but
paul should do something about pro
starvers or something uh confederate
cake stars and bars yeah something
something you know please please paul
because we love paul's artwork here but
right here's the manga king
do you think he actually wears the the
crown when he goes yeah
hundred percent he's like i want the
here
i went the crown give me the crown
you know and then down junior's like
give him the crib joe bear him you know
it's like joe baiden
give him the crown give my father the
crown joe baden there's no burger king
crowns because of joe biden and his war
his war on crowns there's no crowns he's
joe biden jill that in it's time to
replace burger king with mega king like
joe baden
oh my god
oh should we get i don't think we got to
the don junior video yesterday we might
have which one was yesterday the one
where he was all in the house play it
the one with this the formula i don't
know if we played it we already played
this we already uh did he make another
baby formula i don't know
man there's like 100 it's like packing a
hundred pounds of [ __ ] into a two pound
bag with
[ __ ] yeah
100 sounds like hunter yeah well hunter
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yep
hunter [ __ ]
uh have you seen the reports of kevin
mccarthy he's he's seen himself i sounds
like a ton of [ __ ] right i think he's
probably um having to wipe his ass this
morning several times let's listen then
this is scott mcfarlane's um
report on cbs this morning he filed this
report this morning let's listen on
capitol hill the house select committee
investigating the deadly attack on the
u.s capitol has now subpoenaed house
minority leader kevin mccarthy and four
other republican lawmakers the panel i
just want to point out something here um
because we we know kevin mccarthy is
such a [ __ ] i think you're just gonna
say we know kevin mccarthy personally no
no no i mean i i i i text mark mark
meadows because apparently everyone has
his number yeah i know you're supposed
to text him um you don't actually text
kevin mccarthy what you do is you get
him on the phone and you record the [ __ ]
out of him is what you do um but this
scott perry guy i'm not really sure who
this this [ __ ] is but of course
we know these three other sons of
[ __ ] yeah jim jordan he showed up on
our bonehead of the week poll
um and that really that really is you
know what you know the reason why
uh jim jordan wanted to serve on the
january 6th committee
yeah turns out he got served a subpoena
for the job i wonder why they wanted him
on there yeah i wonder like
especially when you're like uh
so jim jordan can you tell us how many
times you spoke with uh president trump
on january 6 he's like well uh you know
it depends well it depends on how you
define um
spoke to uh right right because i i i i
and then it goes into the whole thing
and depends on what a phone call is is
is yeah it's like what do you know it's
like sure i i called him but it's like
did i call his phone or the burner
phones like which one are we talking
about
oh my god jim jordan uh of course i call
him jim don't repe report sex crimes
jordan that's my uh yeah my famous
nickname for jim jordan it's a long one
but it's it's fitting well you know it's
the truth so yeah
i'm honestly i'm waiting for when george
clooney's documentary about jim jordan
and the sexual uh assault and kind of
blind eye allegations
uh when that documentary comes forward
because that will be very juicy yeah
that would be really sweet if it drops
like as he's having to testify who knows
he very well might just be like
or he's getting voted for criminal
contempt of congress uh mo brooks we
know mo brooks
brooks is the guy who was wearing the
flak jacket the day of january 6. you
know he was going to take names and kick
ass or some [ __ ] yeah um and that and
now he hates trump
yeah i know
he's totally against trump and you know
what i'd actually treat lovers
well yeah yeah because he was on local
news like oh i bro i've been telling
trump that that it's over that he lost
and blah blah blah that's not what the
[ __ ] you've been saying i think he was
trying to cover his ass in weeks and
weeks and weeks ago and maybe we should
pull that tape um sometime and post it
that mo brooks mo brooks knew he was in
hot [ __ ]
they're all trying to go on tv and cover
their ass like oh i've made public
statements saying the opposite of what
the truth is like it doesn't matter
after the fact after you tried to
overturn the constitution after you
tried to commit a coup after you tried
to install donald trump as dictator and
king and strip away the american
people's vote it doesn't matter what you
say on the news afterwards that that
doesn't that does that doesn't make a
difference if you say the opposite of
what you actually did on the news you
still [ __ ] did it and i think that's
what mo brooks was doing and it's
probably
probably some kind of private phone
phone call that happened between mo
brooks and uh the manga king the former
guy the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopy pants himself and they probably
got into a spat where mo brooks is like
look i can't defend you anymore this is
ridiculous we're gonna go to prison and
then you have andy biggs i'm here from
arizona who is a good buddy at paul
gosar yep you know they're really good
buddies from the same state let's finish
the uh what scott's report is here paul
wants to speak to them about the events
surrounding the january 6 insurrection
as the committee gets ready to present
its findings to the american public
perhaps as early as next month scott
mcfarland has more on this story
a crime and attack unlike any in
american history has led to a
congressional investigation unlike any
other now after nearly 1 000 interviews
the january 6 select committee has its
sights on five republican congressmen
each of whom has refused to appear
voluntarily including the gop leader in
the house kevin mccarthy the committee
knows mccarthy spoke with then president
trump before during and after the attack
this is very important because they're
going to play kevin mccarthy actually
talking to cbs news live on air the date
of january 6. listen
listen to what kevin mccarthy says
on january 6 after the siege on the
capitol when he realizes
that that all this coup talk and all the
coup attempt was real
something he talked about during an
interview with cbs news on january 6th i
spoken to the president i asked him to
talk to the nation to tell him to stop
this
mccarthy says the current so he said he
said that day he talked to the president
to tell him to stop this i wonder what
he i wonder exactly what he meant by
stop this what this is i think that's
probably what the january 6 select
committee wants to ask him what does
this
mean when you said this in this
interview what is this
what is this
what is it what what what is this what
was it
an investigation is not legitimate and
the committee acknowledges these
subpoenas mark an unprecedented moment
an attempted coup and a violent
insurrection
at the capitol interrupting the peaceful
transfer of power
are unprecedented events as for the
other members called alabama's mo brooks
gave a fiery speech before trump in the
white house ellipse january 6. today is
the day american patrons start taking
down names and kicking
i'm so sad that they censored it really
i know
you know it's it's a sad situation man
because here here what a guy he seems so
fired up right well i mean you know
gaby really wasn't talking about you
know taking names and kicking ass like
you know hang mike pence you know those
sorts of things he was probably talking
about i i don't know what kind of names
you know i'm not sure i'm not sure but
he definitely wasn't talking about
kicking ass and committing a coup a
cheeto dust kangaroo yeah no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no it's not like he was ever involved
in any sort of conversations before that
i know
uh not treason not treason totally
normal just another day at the capitol
with a bunch of tourists
and
windows and stuff
i mean that's that's a normal thing when
you go to the game yeah dude i don't
know i don't know about you but right
that's what it is ty
spot on the coup caucus
uh i just i i feel like i saw it on
twitter there was one day i was like oh
i should make a graphic around like uh
when you know the like cocoa puffs and
it's like oh man i'm cuckoo for cocoa
puffs right but it was like i'm
cuckoo or
yeah cuckoo for cocoa puffs uh but it
was cuckoo puffs instead and then i
realized somebody had designed a cookie
cutter they had already done cereal box
and they beat me to it yeah so so
yeah you're still you're still seeing
butt hurt about it you still seem a
little bit i thought it was i got a
little sour
i was seeing a little sour it was a
great idea i mean
they just got to it first that's what
happens with content you know
because we were talking to brent about
satire and parody and that's one of the
challenges
is the rush to the obvious right like
they make it so obvious and the parody
is so easy sometimes because they are
the parody of themselves like it's so
[ __ ] easy
that it's a mad dash to that whatever
that
that satire that joke is it's a mad dash
to it so let's finish here the committee
says ohio's jim jordan talked to trump
on the sixth and texted white house
chief of staff mark meadows earlier
about
the electoral account and that
congressman andy biggs and scott perry
were both involved in discussions
related to efforts to overturn the 2020
election this is all about distracting
america from their abysmal record of
running america into the ground
all five congressmen
[Laughter]
so for people who who aren't watching
that person who just said it's a it's a
distraction um that seems to be what was
his name perry congressman perry is
harry is that his name yeah that's scott
perry of pennsylvania gary you said
there was something
i thought
maybe it was january 6 but i thought
there was something else that happened
let me see if i can find it
the fact of the matter is is we're
actually going to get to some of this on
the hearings gabe you know that these
hearings start uh june 9th yeah and it
seems like it seems like next week um
we're gonna have more information on
these hearings right they're they're
really starting to to put the story
together and how they're gonna roll
these out who it's gonna be
um it really is starting to come
together and i i believe by next week
i will actually start to have some sense
of what the schedule is going to be for
these january 6 select hearings um that
that are on the the public side so we'll
actually get to see the american people
will see
and be able to
actually you know
compute
the story because that's what they're
saying is the story is going to be
they're going to try to put it in a
linear fashion right so they can tell
this story
of what happened on january 6 like step
by step is that is that your
understanding of what's happening yeah
so yeah from what i've read it's uh
it's
a linear timeline but then what i was
reading last night is that they've got
um
different teams that are focused on
different aspects of january 6. so
they've got they've at least talked
about three teams there's a goal team a
blue team and a green team now what you
mean by team this is teams that were
investigating certain aspects of it is
that what you're saying
or how do you mean by team what do they
mean exactly by teams tell the audience
what that yeah so they've got different
different uh people who serve on the
committee
they are solely focused on identifying
and explaining
that um
uh what is happening within so
uh they're like i said there are three
teams at least that we know of i'm sure
there are more that are focused on other
aspects and so instead of instead of
being like oh this is what happened you
know this is what happened over january
or like leading up to january 6 these
teams go into specific details like the
gold team examines the efforts by trump
and his allies to pressure uh justice
department officials as well as those of
the state level to overturn the results
election the blue team examines how
government agencies and law enforcement
prepared for and responded to january 6
attack and the greed team examines the
tracking of money connected to january 6
including the funding behind the rallies
so those are the only three that we know
of right now i'm sure there are probably
you know a red team a yellow team
whatever and what i'm thinking
is that uh each day
will be focused to those teams they've
all made presentations it's gonna be
probably very similar to what we saw
during the
impeachment trial you know uh
uh jamie raskin going up and giving a
powerpoint presentation going through
the video footage explaining at each
detail at this point in time was this at
this point in time was this you know
like the things that we know for sure is
like when the rallies were held what was
said when they got into the capitol what
trump did or rather did not do
and then responded to after to be like
oh i made a video and i told people to
go home i said i'd love them all that
[ __ ] right but how he just waited in
the oval office and we're now hearing
more and more reports as it's coming out
of just the lack
of action he took during the time that
people broke into the capitol he just
sat in the oval office and kind of
watched this stuff on tv had his diet
coke and laughed and loved at all these
people who were coming in because they
said they loved trump so i think what
we'll find is that each day we'll be
focused on different teams and they can
actually do an in-depth analysis they'll
bring people into question and and uh
support testimony there's gonna be
people who are actual staff members
there's gonna be people who are third
party to capitol hill so we're gonna get
a i think a wide variety a medley
of sorts of people that are going to
come in and add
um testimony and um
and uh their actual kind of expertise on
what they know so the good news is uh
and everyone's been uh hearing this our
listeners that we plan on we plan on
streaming live those hearings uh uh
gavel to gavel as pop put it the other
day on our show um that is the plan for
us to stream those and give live
commentary while it is going so don't
miss that make sure you subscribe to our
youtube channel you do not want to miss
a thing on those days that
we will have those hearings because we
plan on here on the show to be streaming
live we're not sure exactly how it's all
going to play out because we don't know
the schedule yet right but hopefully
sometime next week that a schedule will
start to
formulate itself and we'll be able to
give you guys more of an idea of exactly
how we're going to stream these january
6 hearings because we definitely want
our audience to see them in their
entirety and also give you the
opportunity to listen to commentary
because i think that's part of the plan
gabe is to get as many folks as we can
to come in not just us but to give
commentary pope kfc no totally yeah
maybe we'll have the mizellas brothers
on if we can convince them to come over
and give some commentary i think i think
we probably uh will probably have some
other folks inside the minus touch
network so if you are listening out
there on the minus touch facebook page
you definitely want to tune in um to
that stream that live stream of those
january 6 hearings so don't forget again
to go over to the youtube channel just
go to youtube and type in the tony
michaels podcaster if you're on facebook
there is the link there at the top of
the page and if you're on twitter and
twitch again go to youtube the tony
michaels podcast right speaking of teams
i wonder if there's a meal team six
everyone
is there gonna be a meal team six that's
gonna appear before the
uh the committee i don't know but you
know i'm a meal team six what is this
what is it well
something in the news no i i i just this
is a member of the meal team six i have
oh
marjorie taylor green did you see this
uh this crazy ass video from infowars
here is that she had a car or next to a
car or something looks like i i don't i
don't know if she got lost in a parking
lot what's going on here yeah i'm not
really sure what she's uh doing and what
she's talking about seems uh
like from the q anon universe you know
it's a q a on world game we're just
[ __ ] living it man i am on this ride
every day and i don't know
what new addition to the ride they've
added so listen to this craziness that
the uh the captain of meal team six here
um she she she spouts something about
burning down
farm factories or i don't know what
she's talking about let's listen our
farmers are they stand for all of our
values traditional family values freedom
independence how can she say that that
farmers
are are our anti-lgbtq
how can she say that all farmers
hate women's rights and how can she say
that all farmers want to
want to oppress people's liberty because
that's what she's saying here
traditional family values freedom and
independence and you know it's
projection right like that's she's like
oh they're against gay people they're
against gay people they love they love
to they hate women's rights they don't
they don't want them to have bodily
autonomy and they're for making sure
that we oppress the people that need to
be oppressed like that's what she's
saying here um how could she say that
all farmers are for that i don't think
that's true i really don't believe that
but let's let's listen to what she says
about fires the ability to live um and
sustain yourself and your family off the
land the bible administration democrats
are ruining that and they're destroying
the very important most critical part of
the fabric of america and that is our
farmers and i'm so upset about this it
has me so angry but they're she's so
angry she's always so angry like i you
know i get pissed off and i say stay
pissed but she is like the king of angry
right
yeah no sorry i just can't i just only
focus on her fingers that came up out of
nowhere
well i mean she does have five fingers i
don't know if five fingers and four toes
yeah right right well i guess eight toes
total but right right right uh yeah
marger taylor green man she is a
a wacko baby um she is
uh you know rant
she's one of those people that just kind
of like rants to rant you know and i
don't think there's any kind of cohesive
or coherent thought process that happens
she kind of goes off
cubanon is a hell of a drug gabe it's a
hell of a drug it is one hell of a drug
i got hooked on it and dope in [ __ ]
2020.
i had a [ __ ]
guy had to go through withdrawal it was
crazy instead of dope sick your doof is
sick yeah let's listen listen this is
the part about the fires here this is
the dismount doing it on purpose i mean
they want they want to be the global
economy they want to be completely
involved and here we have these random
supposedly accidental fires at food
processing plants
what
we have the supposed accidental fire
what the [ __ ] is she talking about i
don't know
i've already i've
i've already
you wanna this is how my mind works when
i watch these videos
i already know how i'm gonna use this
video but i'm not gonna tell anyone
because i've because previously i've
said stuff on this show
somebody [ __ ] takes a tweet
somebody makes it so i'm not going to
tell anyone what it is but i know
exactly how i'm going to use this video
well here we go
download download upload
splice get ready yeah get ready
did you know did you know that there's
rifts in the q anon world though like
there is huge wedges oh my god there's
like corn open ah man because they can't
all get on the same q and on page like
they can't get on the same page of
craziness do you know who this guy is
yeah this guy's a he's a he's a guy that
uh you know committed fraud uh campaign
campaign finance fraud yeah you mean you
mean he's committed committed election
fraud
no not election fraud right because well
he donated he he made payments to a
campaign he shouldn't so i guess
election fraud but it wasn't as if you
were trying to
yeah so well the other the other thing
too is that if people don't remember in
2014 he pleaded guilty
when he said he's guilty
yeah yeah it wasn't like oh you go to
trial and i'm innocent and then you got
convicted he went and was like guys i'm
guilty i in fact
did this illegal thing i
campaign finance fraud my bad my bad
guys i'm i'm guilty then in 2018 trump
said
uh great people great people uh
dinesh d'souza and then he
gave him
um
what did he give him
yeah why am i blanking on this name
right now uh he
he
he [ __ ] gave him uh
wow why is my i can't i don't know his
word right now you know at the end of
the year when the president you know he
goes through a list of people why am i
blanking on this somebody give me the
answer
it starts with the p
come on
p i i don't i don't know what you're
talking about gosh
the point at the point i think you're
trying to make here though uh as you uh
as you get through your brain farts here
is that um
pardon oh my god why could i not think
of that that was so you couldn't think
of the word pardon yes
oh my god this has been a super long
week you know excuse me pardon me pardon
me oh don't don't you dare tony don't
you [ __ ] oh this is this is totally
and now that now the chat's just full of
this word part oh god pardon pardon me
pardon me pardon me
okay listen guys it's been a really long
week i've been up late making videos for
you all it will come be coming out soon
don't let them lie they're totally
they're totally all on only fans over
there okay he's been really trying to
get his tony will tell you i sent him
messages of a prop that i made for a
video about shooting should i
should i show the audience the uh
yeah you know what show the audience
what i sent you
yesterday
uh let me see if i can i don't even know
if i want to pull it up oh pull it up
baby show the people show the people
what i sent you okay well let's let's
listen while uh while old guilty here is
uh is talking about his movie two
thousand mules and how he hates tucker
carlson he hates tucker carlson because
tucker carlson just isn't queuing on
enough for dinesh d'souza let's listen
important point to realize here is that
with fox news with a lot of things
things aren't the way it seems you know
i look on social media there's tucker
he's sort of he's wearing his
fisherman's jacket he's got aw shucks
added he's one of the guys but behind
the scenes this is how these people
operate they're nasty they're vicious
they threaten you they try to strong-arm
you it's be it's our way or the highways
let us steal your trailer pretend it's
our content and if you if you object you
know you're banned permanently from the
show i mean this is a very dysfunctional
way of operating so at the very least i
think it's decent if you want to ask me
what the next step is to issue a public
apology um and say hey listen we treated
this guy badly we shouldn't have done it
this way um and so i'm appealing to
suzanne scott the um
who's the head of fox uh to introduce
not just some discipline but some
civility into something that has i think
quite clearly gone off the rails
important point to realize here is that
with fox news with a lot of things
things aren't the way it seems you know
i look unso so he's really upset at
tucker girls and like he's big mad big
mad at tucker okay so i'm sorry when he
went through that and he was explaining
uh these people they co-op they take it
for their own he was not talking about q
because it sounds like he was talking
about q you're saying that he wasn't
talking about q
because tucker carlson isn't q enough
right
well i guess
the problem that they have is
they really want to get this this
lioness [ __ ] this um
this
2 000 mules thing right right have you
heard this
yeah yeah yeah i mean nick n uh if if he
wants to uh tell us how the the
the the movie was right he watched it
well i mean oh did someone in the chat
has watched the movie i mean it's not
probably hard to understand what the
movie is these people are easy to
predict as far as as far as what they do
with these things but dinesh d'souza is
obviously very [ __ ] pissed off at
tucker carlson the tucker carlson
absolutely will not
will not uh give him the light of day as
far as this movie goes because it
doesn't suit
um tucker carlson's fancy
to tell this lie like it's way too cute
too much queuing on too much going on
too much conspiracy theory for even fox
news
and here's the thing turns out you may
be able to od from q
right
well
here's the other thing too that i think
people need to remember is that the
crazies need fox news this is more proof
just just this video here where he's
basically calling out tucker carlson
that the crazies need fox news that fox
news have enough crazy they don't need
all the crazy like they can manage with
the crazy that they already have and
they already have i mean that's i mean
look at it i mean here when ben shapiro
says that two thousand emails is not
proof that that is saying a lot that is
that and uh that's more proof
that two thousand meals is a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] right
because apparently um in the movie and i
guess this movie that that they produce
these q and honors have produced uh with
the help of dinesh d'souza um apparently
they say oh it's not about the votes
it's about the ballots and it's like but
the vote are on the bet but the you use
a ballot to tony don't don't don't think
about it don't try to think about it
what i've learned what i've learned from
uh the republican mindset cueing on and
maggie and all this stuff if you don't
think about it it makes complete sense
yeah
absolutely i mean that's the only way
that it makes sense is if you just
if you just
drink a big glass of kool-aid
and don't think about it yeah um you
know they're they're afraid of the truth
right they're terrified of the truth
just as just as much or almost as much
as they're terrified of chalk um
everyone knows that you're making a
chalk video yeah yeah and you said
i filmed it last night
uh after only fans or before the
afternoon i had to make sure i got the
good stuff right right right well um
gabe actually text me this picture
audience um now for context no no no no
context you don't get the context out of
this
so here's the thing here's the thing is
when it popped up on my phone
i almost thought at first
that i might have been receiving an only
fan's pick from somebody um you decide
for yourself here is the picture that
gabe uh sent me
now this may or may not be
uh
a homemade piece of edible chalk um
and um
made out of candy
but it it
gabe it really it does appear to have a
um oh what would snickers what would
snickers call it a dick vein is that
what dick pain the vein is back baby
let me pull it up again
yeah i could see that you know too bad i
want some like john madden
uh just like drawing he's like so the
dick vane goes up here you know
you know it looks like you know there's
also this white powder here i don't know
what's going on there you know it seems
like a
it was a crazy night of filming i just
saw it
oh my god can you guys imagine me
looking at my phone it was like 11 30 at
night yeah and here i send him the good
stuff right before he goes to bed right
and here we go here i get this picture
tony sweet dreams tony of this of this
uh [ __ ] vein dildo whatever this thing
is and he's like i'm gonna i think i'm
gonna eat this is what he is yeah i
think that's the text that you put was i
think i'm gonna eat this yeah i'm gonna
eat this whole thing the whole i did not
eat the whole thing i just
so what is this what is this um
maybe maybe an edible piece of chalk
that has possibly a dick vein in it what
what did you make this out of because
it's homemade yeah yeah so
i made a video about chalk cops
and there's cocktail [ __ ] yeah
cop chalk
chalk chalk chalk okay
[ __ ] cops [ __ ] okay chocolate chocolate
choc cops okay that makes sense that
makes sense yeah
so the premise of the video
uh which maybe i'll be able to finish up
and release later today is a cop shows
up to the crime scene
um or rather he shows up to the chalk
scene and
he is investigating this whole thing and
he's talking to two other cops another
one is totally knows who this guy is
and this other rookie cop
uh has no idea who this guy is
um and thinks everyone is kind of
overreacting
so
this is uh that is just a prop one one
prop for uh you know the world the world
that i create for the people that watch
the videos you know so don't say i
half-ass this [ __ ] okay
he's dedicated he's dedicated
he's dedicated to his art folks yeah
he's he's even willing to go outside
chalk edible chalk i made it i made it
oh my god
oh my this is i'll tell you i'll tell
you what the ingredients were you know
go ahead go go ahead tell us what the uh
[ __ ] chalk
whatever whatever calcium carbonate
sodium chloride
and mountain dew code red
is that how you got it to be pink no no
that's not the actual ingredients but
that's what i say in the script oh i see
i
we're going to put out a craigslist ad
for a new executive producer and co-host
uh that doesn't mean
it's friday the 13th see ya what one one
more thing um one more time before we go
to a break because before i before i
leave okay yeah well we're going to do
bone end of the week and depending on
how good you do on bone of the week
we'll see i think the audience likes to
keep you around especially for pictures
like this i mean um for the edible
dick vein [ __ ] chalk excuse me yeah
sidewalking
yeah
so everyone everyone make sure to pay
we're gonna get flagged youtube is gonna
be like is that a dick that's a dick
oh youtube's definitely gonna make us
cut this part out i know uh without
without hesitation so
don't forget to go follow gabe at
i am gabe sanchez on twitter because i'm
sure and on the instagrams and the tic
tacs
you're definitely going to want to see
this because um
anyone loves a good
dick vein chalk
thing if if that you want to watch
a character that may or may not look
like gabe sanchez eating this thing
right here
um in a video you may want to go follow
you may want to go follow
absolutely okay everyone we're gonna
we're gonna do bone end of the week um i
don't know if gabe's gonna show up on
bone end of the week uh if he is the
bonehead maybe he's not somebody
somebody said uh
hold on hold on here we go midas margie
said gabe is [ __ ] of the sidewalk oh
ooh
uh who said someone said a 420 god said
i i am gabe sanchez he is he is i am he
is sanchez yeah yeah
yeah
yes i am it's at i am gabe sanjay's yeah
his social medias his social media i'll
put it in a chat for the people i am
gabe and sanjay so go follow and don't
miss don't miss the uh
the sidewalk [ __ ] sidewalk chalk video
sidewalk do the do the do the [ __ ] walk
do the no that's not all right all right
everyone we're gonna go to break we'll
be right back
as i get my executive producer under
control here all right don't just stick
around we'll be right back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dears tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
enough of the
sidewalk [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] talk
oh boy
you guys know what happens in the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast every
single friday
bonehead
of the week
this is this is this is one of my
favorite parts of our show all week i
swear i the whole week i'm just like
bone head bone head bone head bone head
bone head i will have to tell the
audience that last night um i had to
text gabe i'm like hey bonehead of the
week post and he's like yeah
and he posted it and he's like you got
youtube so i went over and posted on
youtube so yeah second week in a row we
did it we did it
youtube twitter so don't don't forget to
uh follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod to get your vote in on
bone end of the week and if you if you
don't want to go on the tweety tweets of
the trendy trends uh subscribe to the
youtube channel and you'll be able to
find the bone end of the week poll there
because here's what happens folks if
you're new listeners
we put out a poll for bonehead week it
has three contestants you vote you
decide who the bone end of the week is
and then what happens is we break it
down on bone end of the week
well look at that look at that
transition boom
boom boom boom end of the week wow wow
so we have some we have some great
boneheads um this week there was also
every week every week and we actually
you you switched the honorable mention
like last minute here right last minute
it was like literally game time decision
i did it at like 9 00
am i made the choice executive call
because that's what we do as an
executive producer because i make
executive calls because we were gonna go
on air
and gabe says [ __ ] it i'm making x
the dutch honorable mention like right
before we went on there
before gotta do it that's how we think
on our feet here at the tony michaels
podcast that's why you should always
join us
um at the tony michaels podcast uh thank
you thank you maxwell for the super chat
bonehead of the week super chat i gotta
make one i gotta make a
uh
[Music]
a gift for
for this one yeah we should we should
make a special gif a dancing gif yeah or
the bonehead of the week
um
super chat but you know you've been
saying you're going to work on a ted
cruz one
maybe because he's a bonehead so i feel
like that should be it
that could be it that could be the
perfect graphic for this one right here
exactly is the super chat gif 4
for bone end of the week and speaking of
that
let's do bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
to this edition of bonehead of the week
hey boy did we have some boneheads this
week it has been a boneheaded type week
um speaking of your homemade shock um
one of the boneheads was susan collins
we all know she was terrified of chalk
and she had to call the she call the
chalk police yeah jim i don't report sex
crimes jordan showed up as a contestant
on bone of the week and then rand i love
vladimir putin paul
i think he also goes by uh
senator rand uh my neighbors hate my
[ __ ] guts paul
oh well that that's a good nickname for
him too yeah someone he has many he has
many different aliases or nicknames and
that's just a couple that we named
you know rand paul when he trends it's
really it's really crazy because like as
soon as he does something rand polish
which is
pretty much every day like he goes a
straight up to the top like he doesn't
[ __ ] around rand paul doesn't hover down
like at number 20 or number 18.
paul goes straight to the top of the
trending people like [ __ ] this guy we
hate this this perm um debbie thank you
uh for the super chat have you ever
worked is that for me or is that for
tony who is that for i don't have you
ever let me i don't know that they let
me i don't know
like series don't come anywhere near you
say too many curse words to be a
substitute teacher and that that
probably wouldn't be a good idea debbie
um but i mean i don't know exactly what
kind of substitute teacher that we would
be but probably not in a school
where they could hear bad words that's
yeah you saw him that's all i'm i'm
guessing
uh dennis dennis michaels says john
melendez lies to your face
is he related to you proof by the coors
on me i i i no no i i don't know dennis
i thought he was like maybe your cousin
or something thanks for the super chat
um
i i we were on stuttering john's podcast
and he's got folks if you guys don't
know john john's got a lot of uh got a
lot of trolls out there that like to
troll him so because we've been on his
podcast they've been
they've been heading on over to uh to
our platform
tony tony and i've talked about this
like i mean i get a ton of hate on my
own stuff that i post online and tony
does too and so we welcome the trolls
here please
come and engage with the content let's
do it let's do it pump those algorithms
baby
pump those algorithms um
speaking of uh
pumping dude
who
i gotta i gotta figure out uh oh i see
who the winner was because it was really
close wasn't it yeah it was real close
like how close was this race here we're
talking like
five percent difference between the
winners
of so across the polls because we yeah
across the polls yeah yeah but here's
the thing it was uh relatively the same
on you know the the numbers were a
little different but it was the same
choices roughly were made
uh between twitter and youtube so it's
interesting to see that oh i see so so
you're saying that the polls are pretty
consistent across the board is that the
i think elastic was pretty close and
today was uh i mean here what i'll say
is it even got a little bit closer um
maybe because somebody was trending
but you know
the end poll result on twitter was like
actually
two percent different
right so here is the contestants susan
collins jim jordan i don't report sex
i'm jordan and rand i love putin paul
here's the twitter results of course
this isn't the uh
the
the reflect oh i mean i guess it might
be a reflection but it is but it is very
close here you see i i'm kind of
disappointed
in the votes here that jim jordan only
received nine percent this bonehead
definitely deserves much more the nine
percent in this race um jim jordan has
been you know really conditioning
himself for years to be bonehead of the
week this should be
uh cause for concern for uh jim jordan's
career and in the bonehead of the week
contest gabe i'm trying to do sports
commentary these days yeah i know it's
totally fine i mean like here's the
thing this week was pretty close you
know they were neck and neck for
most of the race
uh i will say this when when the poll
was launched last night
uh i was following nobody voted for jim
jordan in the first like 30 minutes are
you serious
nobody nobody it was just zero percent
it was like it was almost 50 50
the whole time from the beginning like
when i voted there were already 30 votes
and it was 50 50. oh man i i i'm afraid
that jim jordan's career um as a
bonehead of the week contestant boy this
is this is he's not looking he's falling
off the charts here yeah a little bit
concerning honestly you're right right
he really needs to step up his game
maybe run a few uh boneheaded laps yeah
um you know and maybe maybe maybe the
film from george clooney would help out
jim jordan for bonehead of the week
i'm super excited for that documentary
film good limited series whatever it is
as long as it exposes jim jordan for the
goddamn hypocrite
that he is
keep in mind jim jordan hasn't passed
one piece of legislation while he's been
as representative for the state what's
legislation gabe what is that it is um
is that something that legislators are
supposed to do then uh you know if you
look it up in the dictionary you know uh
if you open this thing that's full of
paper
right it's printed
on here it's got words in it it's got
words
are a bunch of letters
um that can range in anywhere from one
letter to uh you know long several
letters right right so and letters
though letters are um
shapes
that are made
to form
uh uh words you know
you know it's i mean we can break it
down we can break it down even more you
know you know
in that book that you're talking about i
bet there is a definition for the word
dictionary in that book there's probably
yeah it's super meta yeah probably it
just says it just says this this yep um
and no and thank you for the uh super
sticker um also we have we have crows
here have you guys ever thought about
going to dc and asking republicans funny
questions it's funny that you would ask
that we actually talked to someone about
that on a show
um if you were listening and i think i
think you're alluding to that show
uh kathy also
with the with the uh super chat you're
gonna miss jim saki
uh speaking of um
of
boneheaded moves i actually i don't i
don't like the jinsaki's leaving do you
do you no no
i don't i think but you know like i
think that i i think i think the sake
bombs or rather just the the the ducey
dunks we'll call him i'm gonna call him
i'm gonna call him a ducey dunk
okay the ducey dunks will continue
post gen saki era so so we don't have to
call it a sake bomb anymore
i always i always think uh ducey as a
dump but do you see dunks sounds pretty
good you know the hashtag
hashtag doocydunks hashtag doucheydunk i
called it right here right now so i i i
like jensaki i think she does a
wonderful job as the press secretary and
that's why i think it's a bone-headed
move but you know again i'm i'm not
calling anyone up specifically a bonus i
just think it's a a bad move at this
point in time now um they have announced
that there is going to be a new press
secretary
um and and i think she'll do a wonderful
job too gabe you you actually uh posted
something congratulating me uh john is
it john p is that what's what's her last
name um
john pierre is that the john pierre yeah
uh i think she'll do a wonderful job too
brian john pierre yeah but the i i think
she'll do a fantastic job at the ducey
dunks but boy i'm just not ready
to call it quits on the sake bomb i'm
just well here's the thing i'm sure
because she's going over an msnbc so i'm
sure that the sake bombs will continue
and potentially a more
fiery format yeah i don't know i i i
just
was she getting her own show or she just
a correspondent i'm not sure i'm not
sure what the the deal is with the uh
with shocky going to msnbc i think i
think again it's a bone-edited mistake
um if you want to know the truth i think
um she better serves the country she's a
very good press secretary she's
uh snappy she's witty she's smart and uh
again she not only dumps on ducey she
dunks on a lot of people and she kind of
puts the press where they where they
need to belong
um and and so i'm i'm i'm not excited
about her leaving because i i love to
watch the juicy the ducey dunks as it
will be from now on
but the sake bomb was fantastic so i
hope i hope we can continue it and it's
not as boneheaded as it seems so let's
go to
i do uh
speaking of boneheaded stuff
so jim jordan obviously um we know the
reason why
he has uh showed up in this poll we were
talking about it earlier
because he is going to be
subpoenaed he's probably going to have
to appear before the january 6th
select committee or he might be held in
criminal contempt is that your read on
this i believe kevin
knows i don't know exactly what the
timeline is if you just say here's the
thing so
scott uh
scott perry right repair scott perry
yeah the guy from uh pennsylvania and
jim jordan
the reason that i remember
scott perry is because he was one of the
people who preemptively
said i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
participate i am not going to testify i
will not work that with the january 6
committee like i'm not if just i'm just
not going to help them out at all
uh and i think that was
back in
earlier in 2020
late 2021 i think potentially like
december 2021
i think is when he made this kind of a
statement
but
now we look at this and these people are
i mean like you know bill barr is
another person
or not bill barr
c bannon is another person who is
holding contempt they have you know he
has a trial later this summer in july i
think if that hasn't been pushed
um
so i don't know what the timeline is if
you say no i'm not going to work with
you i'm not going to give you this like
then
how the whole held and contempt kind of
thing works out for representatives or
other people who are lawmakers on the
hill
yeah and and here's the news from scott
mcfarland uh flash house select january
uh january 6 committee subpoenas
house gop letter k leader kevin mccarthy
i think that's very significant but it's
also significant like you said jim
jordan scott perry mo brooks andy biggs
as part of this growing investigation
because this doesn't just mean that one
person as in kevin mccarthy the leader
but his lieutenants and then and all
this shenanigans
are going to be part of this growing
investigation
names that you see missing here and
pretty significant i think
um are
some other names marjorie taylor green
lauren bobert have they been also
subpoenaed or do you think they will be
i think
they will be
um
i don't think they have yet there's no
there's been no look at them but i i
would considering the fact that you had
people like margie taylor green who are
questionably you know
uh you know planning you know she had a
video where she was like oh we just had
a great meeting planning this you know
stop the steal and then you got lauren
bobert who was actively you know she
tweeted nancy pelosi's location on
january 6th like i have a hard time
thinking that they wouldn't
uh
you know go after her
um or or both of them
so i don't know if it's i don't because
i also know that during the january 6
public hearings that they are not going
to bring everyone back
so i'm not sure if
they're going to subpoena someone like
that to come in right beforehand
or what you know because there's no
guarantee again like if you deny and
you're like no i'm not going to
participate in this even though you sent
you you issued me a subpoena like what
happens right do you get held in like
capitol hill jail or something no
probably not
right right so they could easily just
flake on it and be like yeah i'm not
doing that at all so i'm not i'm not
exactly sure unless they they have
something that's pretty damning where
they're like oh i do want to set the
record straight
but i'm not sure so i want to move on to
the other
other contestant uh susan collins
we all know there's several different
reasons why susan collins made the list
this week number one is
um
she absolutely refused to vote to codify
roe v wade um but also
she basically she cannot recall she
cannot she feels bad
she thinks that uh you know
brett kavanaugh's telling the truth and
everywhere
and they learn their lesson and on and
on and on it goes with susan collins but
something i want to show you here that i
i found um
is that this is chalk is a dick
no
but this is it's close uh not quite it
says breaking susan collins is
introducing legislation to ban
high-capacity chalk magazines
um you see here i don't know i remember
this i remember it in school yeah yeah
we still had chalkboards when i was yeah
yeah i mean remember by the time by the
time i got out
right on them the thing here too is i
just realized susan collins her her
initials are s
c
yeah sidewalk
chalk oh my god
wait a second wait a second wait a
second i'm just saying there's some kind
of space laser thing going on here i
don't know man i don't know but all i'm
saying is like when i break it down you
know sc susan collins sidewalk chalk it
seems a little bit suspect
this sus is [ __ ] such as [ __ ] um
so let's see if we can find here um
video
of sidewalk jack i mean susan collins
um what was that what was the video i
know what it was it was um
it was minus touch they had the video
what was it called the um
lying gop yeah lion gop is that what it
is yeah uh she's in that one oh yeah
she's a featured she's a featured celeb
on that one for sure let's see if we can
find she doubled down
in several occasions to say that these
people would not overturn roe v wade it
was the law of the land and that uh
you know she could totally trust him and
so can you
um so
if i find this video here it is it is
uh let me pull this video up here and
we'll watch it real quick this will give
you a good idea of susan collins and
then then what we'll do is we'll move on
to our alpha cuck because i think gabe
really wants to move on to
getting to the alpha guy let's listen to
the lying gop from mind as dutch
i believe the constitution protects the
right to privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
[Music]
roe versus wade is an important
president of the supreme court it was
decided in 1973 it has been challenged
on a number of occasions and the supreme
court has reaffirmed the decision when a
decision is challenged and it is
reaffirmed that strengthens its value
roe versus wade decided in 1973
suppressed the united states supreme
court
it has been reaffirmed so a good judge
will consider it as precedent of the
united states supreme court worthy as
treatment of president like any other
[Music]
as a judge it is an important precedent
of the supreme court by it i mean roe v
wade and planned parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
[Music]
i do not believe that here it is
don't you think he's probably going to
vote to overturn roe versus weight if
given the chance
i actually don't
president because
it's overruling have never ceased but
that doesn't mean that
you're terrified of chalk chalk scares
the bejesus out of me
please please save me from the chalk
shock
shock cops please please save me okay so
susan collins obviously she's afraid of
chuck she's also afraid of the truth
um and that's why she ended up
on the bone end of the week poll she did
not win though it was very close though
yep it was pretty close man i told you
when it started off you know first 30
minutes the first like 30 or so votes i
saw was literally 50 50. no one voted
for jim jordan
maybe maybe she's learned her lesson and
when she does bone-ended [ __ ] she should
really ramp it up and she should really
ratchet up the bone-headed stuff and she
might have learned her lesson i don't
know uh the next the next the alpha cuck
that we have for the week
is nick fuentes nick flynton
we went on we went on a die raid the
other day about nick fuentes is that why
he ended up as alpha cup gabe is that
why you saw mick fuentes a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman is that is that is that the one
the main reason no no no no no no that's
not at all it's also
his projection of uh
because i haven't ever hooked up with a
woman that you're more gay than me right
because i've been celibate i'm actually
more straight than you bro yeah that's
that's kind of alpha cuckish doesn't it
and then there's the other video that i
showed you that we pulled up on the show
which is when he goes the most
appropriate manner in which someone
could hit on him would be if there was a
subordinate in a workplace environment
where the secretary hit on him as the
boss
so nick fuentes really lives in this
weird ass celibate
1950s
uh
male dominated kind of scenario that's
what he wants he wants
back to 1950s woman barefoot in the
kitchen making the meal that would be
under the assumption that he could
actually get a woman that would
willingly want to engage with him that's
disgusting to think about um but yeah
those those three things and just him
being nick fuentes and being the the
nazi that he is right do you think do
you think that like his perfect mate
his perfect mate whether it's a female
or male
um would like spend late nights sitting
up reading mind comp with him exchanging
you know who i think would be a great um
just kind of you know a bunk mate or
just like a roommate or whatever matters
that that could yeah
he's a fan of uh
he's a fan of of of hitler you know
right he went he went to the nest he's
like i went to the you know uh and not
only that but
he's also you know i don't i don't know
you know it's right like maybe they
would they would align politically and
maybe emotionally too right right and
even like if they were laying in bed you
know reading mind conf and that would be
you know
tea bagging for each other super cute in
their own minds they look at this
totally
they'd say ah this is
this is what i've wanted all my life
just another person who loves him as
much as yeah you know we're going to
turn our audience off here giving them
an image of madison gothar and nick
fuentes laying naked in bed reading each
other uh minecomp but let's see what
didn't want to make that image but i'm
just saying they seem to be compatible
at least
emotionally well it could be and
interests well let's hear what nick
puente says about women
who get an abortion to save their life
and possibly the doctors that would uh
save that woman's life with a
with the procedure of an abortion let's
hear what nick fuentes has to say about
what he thinks should happen to the
doctor and specifically the woman the
woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor
whoa
did you get censored bro what happened i
i think i think i did i think i got
censored i think i think did elon just
finish the deal did he just close the
deal is that what happened i don't know
i mean according to the eye guy which we
haven't seen any time recently the eye
guy told us that elon musk
owned twitter he did even though i told
him that he didn't he's right paperwork
doesn't say that he doesn't he doesn't
own twitter he still doesn't own twitter
and remember and he wants he won't own
twitter that's why we named our show
elon won't own twitter exactly and
that's the same reason why i shared the
video of him doing the financial times
panel and he said
i don't own twitter yet right and he was
talking about bringing trump back which
means that he also could potentially
bring back nick fuentes
okay well let's listen let's see if elon
censors us again the woman should be put
in jail too they should all go to jail a
hundred years for the doctor a thousand
years for the woman that's what i say
elon wants to bring this guy back to
twitter and he wants to bring trump back
to twitter so the [ __ ] grabber and the
guy who wants to lock away women for
having a medical procedure right it
seems that seems on brand for
for elon musk and speaking of uh elon
musk
he showed up as our dishonorable mention
at the very last moment
to the audience why
why elon musk ended up as the
dishonorable mention on bone head of the
week right so as you guys know those
have been following you know tony was
like in the beginning he said
not going to happen this deal is not
going to happen from the first day on
the first
very first date like even even even when
even when there was this the the slight
stench
when when it was announced that he owned
like 15 and he wanted a board seat and
all that [ __ ] i was even saying this is
all [ __ ] well at that point at that
point i was like this well at in the
beginning i was like this deal isn't
real this doesn't seem any any sort of
reality to it but then once the 44
billion i was like uh i'm 50 50 right
now it took me two days to look at
everything that was going on and then
come back to say it's not gonna happen
now since then we've learned of more
things that have come out he's got a
lawsuit against him as the ceo of tesla
because he has an agreement that he was
supposed to do a 10-year stint as a
dedicated ceo of tesla un undistricted
like not distracted completely focused
making sure that the company you know
grows and makes obviously the investors
and the shareholders the money that they
were promised right now what ended up
happening is that uh elon musk began to
get distracted he wasn't committed 100
of the time an investor came through and
had a lawsuit against him now on top of
that this twitter deal because that was
independent of this twitter that
happened before twitter deal came out
now once the twitter deal came out that
there was that that was actually going
to potentially go through that it was
spending 44 billion
this investor was like oh great this is
more this is more fuel for my own my own
fire here right now and then
the other side of it is that 44 billion
right now you have to look at where the
44 billion comes from and elon musk
doesn't have 44 billion to his name
which means the money has to come from
somewhere which means that most likely
the places he would actually sell his
stock and his shares to actually get
money to cover part of the cost would be
tesla and we've seen the downward spiral
i think the stock right now is oh i
don't know what it was it was yesterday
was like 735
it is going down month after month the
the the downward spiral
has lost the company billions it has
lost the net worth of elon musk billions
which is hilarious i would say that the
investors are pissed off here don't
think 100
and so these investors then you come to
the new lawsuit which is the orlando
police pension fund now has a lawsuit a
class-action lawsuit against elon musk
and the other twitter execs to say that
this this deal is not
in their financial best interests is
this the is this the the lawsuit that ty
ross wrote about i think ty is in the
chat ty if you can hear uh post the uh
the the link to your article that you
have because it's it's a good article
describing that's the lawsuit that
you're talking about right exactly that
is the one that i'm referring to and you
know yes the intel you know for this uh
odd a lawn this uh we got a little troll
here yes the entire market is down
however
tesla was moving downward before the
whole market had a whole downward trend
so
keep that in mind
and now you've got this orlando pension
fund which says we don't actually want
uh this to happen until 2025 right so
you know hey man you guys like the
police back the blue you should probably
support this lawsuit against elon musk
and twitter
then you've got that and then he gives
this talk at the financial times panel
where he says well i don't own it yet
i'd maybe bring on trump he'd be invited
but trump said he doesn't want to come
on which makes it seem like you know
you're like somewhat confident but
you're also
now stating publicly that you don't own
it yet despite the fact that other
elon stanza and republicans are also
saying that elon owns twitter and and
that you know he's finally uh freeing
them of free speech and blah blah blah
and all this [ __ ]
then
you find out last night the most
up-to-date
uh up-to-date in uh instance is that
uh elon musk says i'm gonna put this
deal on hold temporarily put it on hold
because what i found is that the numbers
of twitter users isn't actually accurate
there's a five percent uh ratio of
twitter users that are actually fake
spam accounts
but mj pointed this out this morning
though and i brought this up earlier
isn't that the re one of the reasons why
he wanted to buy twitter was to get rid
of the bots i mean
he wanted to remove it so now it's the
opposite
he wants a one he wants validation for
the users he says when you join twitter
you should have some sort of
verification process if you verify or
you pay for twitter blue you should get
a blue check mark all this [ __ ] but
remember that
that is exactly right mj's right you're
right this is another case of point
where you look at this and you say
something doesn't add up if you buy
twitter for the purpose of making it an
open platform
a a town square as you as it will and
you want that to be pure
authentic real people and you said that
the way to do that is like oh take a
photo of your id verify who you are it's
going to be an actual name in a photo
it's not going to be some random sock
puppet account or whatever
it does cause you to question what's
really going on here do you think he's
trying to avoid with some of this talk
yes and so that was and that was
something else that i was trying to
avoid the billion dollars is that what
you're going to get right and so first
first uh this uh uh how do you say that
uh auto line
audit um you may not be a troll this is
uh not a troll but way to lose a viewer
ha ha um you know you're still watching
and the other thing too is still
commenting right you're still commenting
so you can
stand here all day long and i don't know
if the viewers know this but we handle
trolls uh a little differently and
especially the elon stand trolls we hand
them a little differently to most people
they would shut them out they wouldn't
put them on the screen
um that's not how we do it here we
actually believe in free speech we
believe in your freedom to say things so
this is i also want to point out that
i've been watching this guy talk in
various shows that we've we've had and
also today oh so you mean you mean this
isn't the first time this person has
been here to listen to this that i would
imagine it's not the last time either oh
yeah this person has been here all day
they've also been talking about how we
were wrong and they were saying that two
thousand mules was evidence oh yeah
absolutely yes
well i mean obviously it's evidence fox
news would play it if it wait a second
maybe i'm wrong yeah so so let's get
back to the one billion dollars because
i actually think that is the most
important part of this entire deal that
elon musk because he he's gonna he's not
gonna buy twitter he never intended to
buy twitter it was all a big [ __ ]
stupid gag to get this the elon stands
like this troll here that's been
listening to us for weeks about elon and
two thousand meals um the reason why
he's been doing this is to pump them up
and get them excited and get them to to
buy [ __ ] and to pump stock uh mj kind of
has alluded to it over the last week and
or two uh as this has gone on when we've
when we've uh
conversated and engaged with people
online back and forth when i said from
the very beginning he is not going to
own
twitter i believe the only thing that
elon is trying to do is trying to buy
time to find a way
to get out of having to pay another
billion dollars because he's lost all
this money and tesla he's probably gonna
lose his uh his ceo ship i i think i
think it is possible within the next
year because of this deal and because of
the boneheaded stuff that he's done
because of this deal he is not going to
be the ceo of tesla he's pissed off
these investors he has proven to them
proven to them that he is not only not
only a [ __ ] [ __ ] and doesn't realize
that you can't just run around saying
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say that
you're going to destroy our investment
they're going to kick him off the
they're going to kick him off well i
mean remember he was under investigation
for tweets that he said about tesla
where he just blew up he inflated the
stock by by promoting and you know
saying certain things on twitter still
under investigation still under or not
investigation but still under kind of
their overwatch which he tried to get
out of recently once this twitter deal
was announced and they're like uh no
dude you're still kind of under our
watch
but the other thing too is like remember
i set it back on april 27th and there
were a bunch of people who [ __ ] hated
on me i said elon musk has roughly 2.8
obviously well maybe less than that now
in cash and cash equivalents he
personally has to cover 21 billion of
the 44 billion twitter deal which still
is not secured and if anything all of
these events that have led up are
probably making the financial investors
the banks the vcs probably a little bit
skittish to say like i don't know if we
have the actual security to back this
guy right now
now there's the one billion dollar uh
breakup fee which by the way either
party has to pay if twitter backs out
they have to pay if elon backs out he
has to pay but he is now there there are
conditions of this right right but right
now he is stuck between a rock and a
hard place you know right so he's trying
to find any way that he can and i think
that's what his is um when this morning
he's trying to use the fact that there's
so many fake accounts quote unquote and
to back out of this uh one billion
dollars i don't know exactly what his
aim is here right but i know elon is a
flake and i know definitely elon will
try to back out of any deal that he
cannot finish actually let me show you
let me show you some evidence of that
watch this clip here he doesn't own
twitter yet and he's a flake let me
prove it this is proof that he's a flake
i know this seems trivial here's a
picture of elon musk with a haircut look
at this here i'll make it bigger he
flaked on his haircut this is not a
finished haircut he did not even let the
barber finish his haircut look at this
guy does this look like a guy that
finishes anything come on give me a
break you know the thing about this clip
gabe that and that i didn't realize
after i made it and posted it
i didn't say one curse word and that and
that whole group
they're like boom no band no suppression
you did it tony you did it i make
content without cursing [ __ ]
but you look at the situation right now
and yes i mean you know there's a lot
that elon musk has flaked on in the past
right like he has uh [ __ ] to bed when it
came to saving the the thai kids in the
cave he [ __ ] to bed when he promised he
was gonna give every flint recipient or
like resident uh clean water in their
homes right instead while still good he
gave filtration systems to schools still
not as great because what happens when
those kids go home what happens when
those kids are out of school during the
summer like not really solving a problem
here so you look and there's there's
also other instances where where elon
musk has [ __ ] the bed or or made
something up or has
uh
you know kind of skewed what he intended
or what he said
but remember one billion dollars a lot
of money twitter has nothing to lose
here right now they have everything to
gain either they get the 44 billion or
they get an extra billion dollar bonus
no they know this guy is gonna [ __ ]
run away and they're they're apt to get
that billion dollars right now i do have
to say gabe i i do want to give elon a
little credit here about his flake ship
um as i call him a flake because i i am
still standing behind 100 000 that elon
will never own
twitter as a private company he may own
stock but he will never own twitter as a
private company um you made this
thumbnail this morning saying epic fail
but i found this picture and sent it to
you and you used it for the thumbnail
yeah i had to go i did i remember the
video because it was on cnn i had to go
to the original source video to get a
higher quality to pull the image yeah it
was when it was after paypal went uh you
know they made their money and he bought
his million-dollar mclaren is this is
this a funny video is it does it
describe elon in
can we play them can you send me the
video yeah because here's the thing
here's what i want to say about this
this photo of elon
i do want to say that his i made fun of
his haircut in the last clip but to be
fair the guy was dedicated
to hair plugs he was dedicated to these
hair plugs
um i don't know how much if he spent 44
billion on the hair plugs or not
but you know
this is
a haircut that is worth getting hair
plugs for so i will give elon
credit
what credit is due to elon
um but if we can find that video from
cnn now this is after he sold paypal
because
he he was um you know he takes credit
for a lot of things that he invented a
lot of things which he did not invent
yeah um which we already know for
remember he did not invent tesla he did
not invent the electric car he is not
this savior hero person that
all these right-wing
you know uh or just elon stands put him
to
um
he is
also on hold on this is hilarious you
lib turds loved him three weeks ago for
what what did we love him three weeks
ago yeah i don't love elon musk i've
never liked elon musk i wouldn't buy a
[ __ ] i wouldn't i wouldn't own a
tesla if you [ __ ] gave it to me not
because i don't like electric cars
because well that's awesome because
today's sponsor is tesla note
brought to you by no [ __ ] tesla i mean i
mean here's the thing if elon musk is
not the ceo which apparently elon musk
is not even uh is working to not even be
an owner at tesla as much stock as he
has to sell to try to get into this deal
that he's not going to do um that he's
going to have to spend a billion dollars
to get out of and then he won't own as
much of tesla as he
says he owns listen elon musk i if he
doesn't own tesla he's not the ceo i
might change my mind about tesla i might
remember that i won't this is something
i mentioned before is that
the position that he has at tesla as the
ceo is definitely at risk right you look
at what's been happening a downward
spiral downward trend of the stock value
which is the overall company value for
tesla you have investors and
shareholders who are not happy because
they're like where is the money coming
from to pay for twitter right
now
the the board can have a vote of no
confidence and i want people to remember
a vote of no confidence means that the
board can then say u.s ceo are not fit
we do not have confidence in you to
continue in that role you can still stay
on that
yeah i know it's crazy it's like almost
like he was distracted from the main
focus for that for making that money you
mean their money and their investment
exactly and he's gonna use that money to
do this little pet project
where what started as a joke and then he
figured that he was too deep into the
joke and he couldn't back out or else he
would look weak and now his ego was
frail and a little bit delicate you know
or always been delicate but a little bit
more tattered and now he has to defend
himself to be i'm the savior of free
speech but
also i'm not going to actually go
through with it and i think at the end
of the day
and i said this in a tweet he's going to
put the blame on leftist he's going to
put the blame on twitter he's going to
put the blame on anyone else the box the
bot it was the bots it was the bots
even though he was the one who entered
into an agreement and he was the one who
said yeah yeah whoever whoever backs out
of this deal one billion dollars and
he's going to blame
litigate and say that actually
he was
the um
he was the one at fault and and or he
was going to say i'm rather not the one
at fault he's going to say everyone else
is at fault and i'm the i'm the victim
here i'm innocent i didn't do anything
wrong i had the best of intentions for
twitter and then he finds out that he
actually isn't gonna go through with it
all right uh ty ross says here um and
these are her words not mine folks
to be fair tony when it comes to
finishing the guy does have like seven
baby mamas so i don't know how many
babies mama's but it sounds it sounds
really trumpy yeah yeah i mean he's got
like eight seven or eight kids where you
know gabe the elon stands here are just
pissed off in the chat here they're
really
good
they're really pissed off they're really
[ __ ] pissed off here in the chat here
and i i welcome them all
i i i welcome all the elon stands to
come and bump the algorithms uh make
sure you go to our twitter page
and really troll us there too don't just
stop at youtube please whoever this
baron von schneider is my god 2000 news
is getting a special prosecutor yeah
okay okay yeah
yeah that's i i believe that more than i
believe elon musk is going to own
twitter actually i believe that way more
than i think any llamas speaking
let's play this video from um the
archived footage of elon's uh hair or
lack thereof let's let's let's listen
[Music]
some could interpret purchasing this car
as
behavior characteristic of a
materialistic breath here's yeah well
here's the there's the there's the
footage is that the one you had to pull
it from yeah oh wait is it spanish
well it's got the subtitles that's right
that's the engine
and are you no i'm not it comes with its
own set of luggage actually or at least
it's not consistent with the rest of my
behavior
cnn.com
[Music]
how you doing
oh look at that look at the phone oh man
he's this guy look at this guy elon musk
speaking iman you know what this reminds
him it looks like the phone that derek
zoolander has he's like god
do you think he still answers the phone
like that probably he's gonna come off
he's like i don't want people tracking
me the other thing i want to point out
to all the elon stands out there this
guy's wearing a tan [ __ ] suit someone
someone someone get a hold of the deep
state this guy is wearing a tan [ __ ]
suit
i don't think he's on the side that you
think he's on or maybe maybe he switched
sides when he took his red pill oh boy
this guy's got a tan suit on this should
be concerned for the 2000 mule trump
bumpers out there
[Music]
i expect to receive
a car that i just bought which is called
mclaren f1
oh this is where it's so he's getting
the delivery of the car yeah yeah and i
will own one of them it's a million
dollars for a car
it's crazy
it's uh it's decadent back in 95
there weren't very many people on the
internet
where's his pipe don't you think he
should have like oh yeah yeah he's
smoking here like definitely and he's
puffing on this is ridiculous suddenly
nobody was making any money at all uh
most people okay i can't even i can't
even take it anyway that was the gist of
it he was there when he got his mclaren
and he was like it's a million bucks and
there's only 62 in circulation at this
moment i'm going to own one of them
right so you know that's what happens
i'm going to buy twitter i own one of
them one stock but i'm going to buy it
sounds familiar i don't know it sounds
funny yep pretty much it sounds sounds
familiar um let's go back to the um to
the boneheads of the week here now that
we've drug elon and the stands are
pissed off at us stick around stan
stick around stamps keep viewing because
if you do we definitely will [ __ ]
dunk on you when elon musk has to pay
the billion dollars to back out of the
deal
can't wait can't wait speaking about
backing out of deals that pay
pay money rand paul
um it ended up on bone of the week did
rand paul win the bonehead of the week
gabe
he did indeed he is the winner opponent
of the week um why was he on the
bonehead i mean there's so many reasons
why rand paul could probably well you
know uh he's a uh
he is a russian asset uh oh
pro putin
you know he's anti-life
pro-putin
he's another he's another uh uh putin
puppet
and so when it came down to hey we
should help uh
uh ukraine defend themselves by giving
them money because you know there's
literal genocide that's happening
between uh ukraine
and from russians yeah i mean the guy he
loves is committing war crimes yeah yeah
yeah exactly
uh but rand paul was like uh you know
per usual uh actually guys like he's
going to come and he's going to try to
stop it
anything if he's going to get back the
real science on this if you look at rand
paul's record you'll find that he either
is holding up people or he's the last to
vote
or he's the only one
potentially that is uh objecting
and um it is
not unlike rand paul it is very much
within his wheelhouse that is what he
does it's on brand he will for every
single moment that is against democracy
he will vote for it
absolutely well and uh it's not
surprising in the chat everyone can see
in the chat that that that the elon
stands are also pro pro-putin as well
and they love rand paul which is not
surprising that they would love a
douchebag like elon musk
and stand for rand paul as well it is
not surprising let's go into the rand
paul thread here because i think it's
important for everyone to check out a
video and here it is
it's very easy to see because if if the
elon stands want to know out there why i
pulled evidence of why he's a flake and
why he wouldn't do the deal here's
evidence of the bone end of the week
winner rand paul
way back when a republican standing on
the senate floor calling him putin's
puppet
long before vladimir putin decided to
commit war crimes in ukraine he was
being called and called out to be
putin's puppet let's listen to senator
john mccain has no argument to be made
he has no justification
for his objection
to
having a small nation
be part of nato that is under assault
from the russians so i repeat again
the senator from kentucky
is now working for vladimir putin it has
no argument whoosh working for is what
he said um tai points may be a good
point out because this this uh elon stan
she's saying it's elon's burner account
elon might be in the chat folks i think
elon might be this baron von schneider
baron schneider
[Music]
elon's um alt account wow this guy's oh
i mean look
say what you want about john mccain but
he's saying brain tumor john mccain is
on par with these two idiots yeah that's
fantastic you know look i'm not a i'm
not a john mccain fan at all really um
if anyone wants to know my stance on
john mccain you can know that my my
adolations for john mccain stop
at his heroic dedication as a soldier
and a veteran to our country
um that's about where it stops because
he picked he picked the vice
presidential candidate that gave us that
gave us trolls like baron von schneider
their voice which is sarah palin um so i
don't have i don't i i'm not a i'm not a
john mccain fan yeah and apparently john
mccain was not a fan of rand paul either
especially rand paul who capitulates to
putin and who is working for putin um i
have a couple other tweets i want to
show here from our favorites um mayo has
one here let me pull it up
she says rand paul is a russian asset
and a traitor to the united states of
america no lies detected
you know uh mayo has a way of just like
just
just saying
just just just typing out exactly what
the truth is push and tweet um and
giving us all
an unfiltered way uh mj
uh with the super chat here ew
oh here she is she is giving a super
chat in the name of baron von schneider
cheers to that she said she loves your
show loves biden and wants to enlist in
ukraine army also says musk doesn't own
twitter and never will
thank you mj for the super chat and
thank you for keeping the elon stands
around yeah for the money for the money
uh what we love we love the elon aaron
von schneider over here keeps he keeps
keeps throwing in comments but i'm sorry
baron you you don't realize that you're
only helping the video right now right
exactly but thank you you should you
should you know keep going put your dumb
ideas into the chat and help the
algorithm tell youtube yeah we should
keep promoting this thing to everyone
else on youtube so we appreciate it yeah
we appreciate all the help we can get
with the algorithms um
so back to back to rand paul so what
he's doing is he's holding up the vote
for this ukrainian effort yeah um to
actually beat back on vladimir putin uh
baron von schneider's uh
lord and dictator here
uh
but really honestly
more than what rand paul's doing because
you remember
what what was it uh two or three weeks
ago he ended up on bone of the week for
the same exact thing do you remember
this do you remember what he did yeah
what did he what didn't he do that he
was he was busy taking his [ __ ] and
holding up the vote for uh
for the scotus nominee right um who was
it brown jackson and but at the time
um he was just you know kind of like
twiddling his thumbs in the stall taking
a [ __ ] scrolling through twitter seeing
everyone that hates him you know not
finding a soul that actually likes him
outside of putin and the dm's that he
gets from him
but yeah he was he held up the vote and
then he came in and then was like nay
right which everyone knew he was gonna
vote it was like literally dude last
year everyone's like waiting like jesus
christ let's go man i want to get to
lunch right even on c-span they put up
on the screen we're waiting on the
[ __ ] rand paul we're waiting we're
waiting on that [ __ ] uh kathy uh with
the super chat says what mj said oh
hell
super chat super chat um rand paul is a
despicable
despicable piece of [ __ ]
and um you know what i'm going to play a
special video
for all of our um
our great elon stands here
that probably actually absolutely love
rand paul and what he's doing to help
vladimir putin
commit war crimes
um
and you know some people were saying the
other day paige rand paul's neighbor
but i i found this video someone had a
wish to a genie
and if they had one wish for a genie
what they would wish so let's let's
watch i grant you one wish
genie make me rand paul's neighbor
[ __ ] him so maybe maybe if there is a
genie out there
we could uh get the genie to make
someone rand paul's neighbor and we
could
settle rand paul down to stay off the
bonehead of the week but let's do this
gabe let's give him his due we are
running out of time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us for bone
end of the week including the elon
stands don't forget we will keep
dragging rand paul susan collins jim i
don't report sex crimes jordan and elon
i don't own and will never own twitter
musk on the bonehead of the week so go
follow us at tony michael's pod where
you can vote
you decide who is the bone end of the
week every single week and we break it
down for you
on friday in the second hour of the show
so don't forget to subscribe on youtube
at the tony michaels podcast just search
the tony michaels podcast you will find
it because we air every single weekday
monday every day friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube and what happens tomorrow tony
on saturday so to tomorrow we do the
best of the week and then sunday
speaking of the week on sunday we clip
out this bonehead of the week and we
post it all by itself not just not just
on youtube twitter twitch but also on
all your podcast directories so make
sure to find it there
on youtube twitter twitch the midas
touch facebook page and apple spotify
google
where you can give us a five star review
that way to help us out with all these
elon stands leaving the bad regulations
but there's actually one more thing what
what is this week yesterday we had an
interview with brent uh
and
we're also going to cut out that
interview so that people can watch it on
this weekend this weekend don't forget
to go to the youtube channel and watch
the full interview with brent there hewn
because we did have some technical
difficulties but yeah yeah it happens it
happens when you're doing a live
yeah whatever when you're doing a live
show thanks for joining us bono in the
week stick around we'll be right back
after the song bone end of the week
folks
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man bone end of the week
another one in the can another week like
i said in the can that's right again
these weeks feel like you know like i
said earlier 100 pounds of [ __ ] and a
two-pound sack right yeah that's what it
feels like with the news that we have
going on now every day is something new
i hope i hope next week we find out um
for sure um rather elon musk owns
twitter or not
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
i hope elon takes over twitter and saves
his baron von schneider because this
person feels a little bit thirsty
for the elon
also feels a little thirsty for the
trump the mega trump the the mega king
all right right right when it happens it
happens it happens thank you all for
joining us
uh this week every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
and also simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page a few announcements
again before we go i want to tell you we
are working hard on trying to figure out
exactly how we are going to live stream
every single one from front to back of
these january 6 select committee
hearings that are going to be public um
so make sure you're staying tuned make
sure you follow us everywhere at the
tony michaels pod so you do not miss our
plans for live streaming those january 6
select committee hearings um it is going
to be very important not just not just
to tell the story but also for america
to finally find out what the select
committee has under their hats we've
seen a bit of it but i think they're
going to tell the whole story in these
public hearings for the american people
to see which will set us up for federal
prosecutions and the federal indictments
that are already underway
uh and the oath keepers and the proud
boys and also it may look like some
people that are higher ups bigger fish
than the fish they already caught it's
friday
time to fry them up baby it's friday so
stay tuned this weekend because we are
going to bring you the best of on
saturday we will bring you the full
interview
with brent terhune so you guys can watch
that and then on sunday we will re-air
bone end of the week of and in itself so
that you guys can watch bonehead a week
alone so go go subscribe thank you nolan
for the for the super chat there we
appreciate all the support that you guys
give us have a great weekend and until
monday surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking